Hey Thoughty2 here.
Politics is a strange thing; it can switch
in an instant from dullness to disaster, from
inspiring to insanity, and from dinner table
chat to fighting in the street.
And much of the problem with it is that when
you align yourself with one particular group,
you feel obliged to stick up for them, for
better or for worse, leading to arguments.
So what about the few politicians that we
can agree on?
Seem like an impossible task, doesn’t it,
surely such a rare creature doesn’t exist
in the wild.
Well, you’re in for a big surprise, because
here’s five politicians that everyone will
love.
First we head to Canada but not for the lustrous
hair of Justin Trudeau.
The Rhinoceros party was set up in 1963 by
Jacques Ferron, a physician and author.
It was intended as political satire, and it
kept going for 30 years.
In a refreshing display of honesty, their
creed was a promise to keep none of their
promises.
They listed their leader as an actual rhinoceros
from a Montreal zoo, called Cornelius the
first, since you need a thick skin to be a
leader.
Members also claimed to be Marxists-Leninists
but rather than having any communist ideals,
it was just because they were fans of Groucho
Marx and John Lennon.
Over the years, some of the party’s policies
included:
• Changing Canada's currency to bubble gum,
so it could be inflated or deflated at will.
• Repealing the law of gravity.
• Providing higher education by building
taller schools.
Although they never won a single seat, they
did occasionally embarrass authentic political
parties, such as when Sonia, a professional
clown, came in second for one of the seats
in 1980.
The party was forced to disband in 1993 due
to a change in the law that would force them
to run for at least 50 seats, at a cost of
$1,000 a seat, that’s far too pricey for
a good old political jest.
In the same year that the Rhinoceros Party
was founded, a similarly satirical approach
was being adopted in the UK by rock singer
David Sutch.
In 1963, he represented a range of different
made up parties in the parliamentary elections,
most notably the National Teenage Party since,
at that time, the voting age was 21, which
Sutch disagreed with.
His band, Screaming Lord Sutch and the Savages,
were not especially successful but their line-up
was constantly changing and they had many
of rock’s superstars before they were famous,
including Jimmy Page of Led Zeppelin, Ritchie
Blackmore of Deep Purple, and Noel Redding,
who was Jimi Hendrix’s bass player.
Sutch returned to politics in the 80s, after
leaving America when he was shot during a
mugging, a fairly solid sign that you don’t
belong somewhere.
He set up the now infamous Monster Raving
Loony Party and was joined by others including
a retired WWII hero named Bill Boaks, who
had been part of the sinking of the Bismark.
Although they never won any seats in parliament,
they did take a number of council spots in
Devon where they spent a lot of time trying
to annoy the Conservatives, with one Loony
Party councilor attempting to pay some taxes
with a pile of metal.
But across the country, they established themselves
as one of the leading protest vote groups
for many years.
Sutch sadly commited suicide in 1999 but,
as was fitting for his party, they elected
Alan "Howling Laud" Hope and his cat, Catmando,
to take over the leadership.
The party’s policies include, putting a
massive mirror in the sky to reflect the sunlight
during the nighttime, so solar panels still
work; introducing a 99 pence coin, to make
it easier to buy ice cream; and bungee cords
shall be attached to the rear of all cars
so that no fuel is used on the return journey.
When Donald Trump announced that Linda McMahon,
the co-founder of wrestling franchise WWE,
would be a part of his new government, a group
of Mexicans deserved credit for their groundbreaking
work 20 years earlier.
In 1996, a wrestler named Superbarrio ran
for President of the United States and arranged
rallies on both sides of the Mexican border,
promising to do away with border patrols and
the Drug Enforcement Agency.
Although he dressed in a red and yellow Lucha
wrestling outfit, Superbarrio was a true political
activist, rather than a comedy figure.
Unfortunately, his attempts to wrestle his
way into the political ranks were unsuccessful.
Dick Augustsson is a Swedish IT entrepreneur
who, when he grew tired of endless jokes about
his first name, decided to change the whole
thing and become Rick Falkvinge, or Falconwing,
as it’s translated.
Through his love of technology, he was part
of the early file sharing communities so,
when the internet copyright debate began to
pick up internationally in 2005, he decided
to get involved by setting up the Pirate Party.
His domain got 3 million hits in the first
two days.
But he wasn’t just casually dipping a toe
in to politics; he quit his job, took out
a large bank loan and really put his heart
and soul into the party.
Within a year, he made the international news,
as a voice criticizing the raid on The Pirate
Bay, a famous file-sharing site based in Sweden,
don’t know why I’m telling you that, you
know what The Pirate Bay is.
He only managed 0.63% of the vote in 2006
but by the time the European Elections came
around in 2009, he won the massive majority
of the youth vote, taking 25% of those under
30 and over 7% overall.
He’s been recognized around the world as
a key figure in bringing the internet into
politics, well before we started electing
people on the basis of emails and twitter…
ah, the good old days.
If you are going to elect a bad-tempered ape
with no idea what it’s doing, Brazil at
least decided to go for an actual chimpanzee.
Tiao the Chimp was estimated to have received
a massive 400,000 votes in the 1988 election
for mayor of Rio De Janeiro.
He came third out of twelve candidates, or
to put it another way, nine actual human politicians
were beaten by a monkey.
The Chimp eventually died of diabetes because,
as the saying goes in Brazil; with great power
comes great amounts of churros.
Thanks for watching.